there's been so much conversation about
what happened at the 2024 Olympics these
ceremonies that have all these cryptic
messages and so many Christians have
come on and said look they were mocking
Christ in the opening ceremony and you
know what they actually took down that
ceremony you can't even find it online
anymore but when I watched Christians
break down what each ceremony was about
I really didn't see a lot of explanation
it was really just kind of things like
you know this kind of looks weird this
looks creepy it's Eerie what do you
think I don't I don't exactly know what
I see here but isn't it weird we're
going to talk about what's really going
on we're going to get into this and
we're going to break it down and find
out exactly what these ceremonies are
talking about what they are trying to
push into the minds of humanity as
people go to what they think is a a just
a familyfriendly sporting event and when
they get you in that event they're going
to make you sit through their rituals
their ceremonies they literally call
them ceremonies we're going to get into
this we know that the opening ceremony
we keep hearing about it you see the
news is even talking about it this isn't
just Christians talking about this it
says uh in Olympic scenes draws scorn
but did they really parody The Last
Supper notice they're saying that this
uh opening ceremony was a mockery of the
Last Supper but some people are
skeptical I want to get into what a
ceremony means they they call it an open
ceremony what is a ceremony it is a
religious ritual that's the term that's
what the term means so when you go to
these events and they have these
halftime ceremonies or opening ceremony
or closing ceremony you are
participating in their religious ritual
and now we see that they had the the
Last Supper drawn out and it was all
these drag queens and even a child in
the midst why would you have a child
amongst these drag queens well it's
nothing new in America we have drag
queen Story Hour at your public school
but was it really the last supper or was
it the Feast of gods that's kind of the
the argument here because a lot of a lot
of people who aren't Christian are
saying oh these uh weak Christians you
know they just want to complain about
something it had nothing to do with the
Last Supper it was really this Feast of
gods well I think it's interesting
because in this article by the rap the
Paris Olympic producer said that it was
inspired by the Last Supper so are we
going to argue with the producer you
know this isn't just a bunch of
Christians whining and complaining this
is literally what these events do they
are out here trying to mock Christianity
they're everything everything Hollywood
does everything the mainstream media
does puts God down puts Christians down
and glamorizes the Occult New Age
practices Satan himself you'll see
people walk around with Satan horns and
at these Grammy Awards and they'll throw
up the horns with their hands and they
just make it look like yeah this is a
fun party I think it's interesting that
Beyonce was a part of the Olympic
ceremony I don't know what she has to do
with sports but she was representing the
USA and do you remember that she had
these different photo shoots with
different horses and people were
starting to put it together that these
were the horses of Armageddon you see
the White Horse the red horse the Black
Horse and The Pale Horse
I don't think any of this stuff is
accident anything done in Hollywood or
in the music industry or any of this
stuff nothing is by accident there's
always a writer there's always a
producer there's always someone that's
checking all the checks and balances
before this stuff gets out into the
public eye nothing is coincidence
nothing is by accident also Megan the
stallion interesting name that she's
called the stallion she was she had a
commercial for the Paris Olympic
and behind her you see four horse four
horses why four horses why is she
dressed in Scarlet with gold and
precious jewels all over her body and
one might say that she's even like a
harlot you look at her and all these
music videos and she's barely dressed so
why is there this Harlot dressed in
Scarlet decked in Gold when Revelation
17:4 says and the woman was AR Ray and
purple and scarlet color and decked with
gold and precious stones and Pearls
having a golden cup in her hand full of
Abominations and the filthiness of her
fornication this woman is a harlot is
full of Abominations and fornication
what does this all have to do with the
Olympics if you watch if you go back in
time and look at some of the ceremonies
the Rel religious rituals of the past
you will see that those things came to
pass you'll see that there was uh one
event that had all these hospital beds
and kids that were sick in them and and
all these nurses were dancing around in
this giant puppet of a a grim reaper or
death had a magic wand and was causing
everyone to be sick and years later
there was a pandemic a worldwide
pandemic what did that ceremony have
anything to do with a sporting event
with an Olympic ceremony um it didn't
but these things are just they they put
it out there and people think it's just
Mindless entertainment and and all of a
sudden those things come to pass I saw
that in one of the the previous Olympic
ceremonies there was a giant scroll like
the size of a football field and they
were unrolling the scroll and when you
read Revelation it talks about a scroll
that no man could open except Jesus I
believe these things all have meaning I
believe all these religious rituals
ceremonies as they call them are not
mindless entertainment they have meaning
what is the meaning I believe it's the
elitists are telling telling you who
they serve and just as a Christian would
try to put Christian uh themes in in the
artwork that we make these people are
doing the same thing they're showing you
who they serve they're showing you that
they are going to be the masters of this
world that they're going to be the
winners and be victorious in this final
battle against Christ but we know that's
not true according to prophecy uh there
was also another horse uh there was
these
interesting angel wings in the
background but there was a rider on this
horse that was running across the water
interesting because who's the only
person that ever walked on water Jesus I
believe that this is an antichrist this
is a being that is proclaiming himself
to be a savior or a Christ and when you
see in the background you see all the
nations of the world represented every
flag is following behind this pale horse
rider and the scriptures say in
Revelation 68 it says and I looked and
behold a Pale Horse and his name that
sat on him was death and Hell Followed
With Him and power was given unto him
over the over the fourth part of the
earth to kill with sword and with hunger
and with death and with the Beast of the
earth I believe that we are facing tough
times up ahead I don't think it's a
shock or a surprise to anyone that the
economy is crashing that uh farmers are
being told by the government that we're
we we will pay for your land and if you
refuse we're going to burn up your land
I've seen videos where farmers are
literally opening up letters from the
government that are saying if if you
don't take our offer we are going to
burn your crops there's so many like cow
pastures that are getting caught on fire
and uh just different different things
that are happening to the crops of our
world that are preparing for a famine to
come there is sickness coming we hear
the people say this all the time when
the when the fourth wave comes when the
fifth wave comes like they are already
predicting these things I believe this
is the predictive programming that is
put out by the elites and they're
showing you their prophetic Vision God
has his prophecies and Satan has his
prophecies and he shows them through
movies cartoons uh sporting events
anything that's publicized on worldwide
television and then you see in
Revelation 13:3 it says and I saw one of
his heads as it were wounded to death
and his deadly wound was healed and all
the world wondered after the Beast and
that's what I'm seeing here in this
image is all the world following this
Rider of this pale horse on this beast
and all the world is wandering after it
trusting that this is our sooncoming
savior then at the closing ceremony the
climax of this whole thing was this
golden person called the golden Voyager
you notice these feathery Wing looking
things coming out the sides of his body
and this person this golden Voyager was
being uh descended from the ceiling all
the way to the ground who else was a
angel that came from heaven and came to
Earth and we see that Ezekiel 28:13 says
Thou Hast been in Eden the Garden of God
every precious stone remember what that
being looks like this golden being every
precious stone was thy covering th the
Sardis the topaz and the diamond and the
barrel and the ANS and the Jasper and
the sapphire the emerald and the
carbuncle and gold Satan is described as
being covered in Gold the workmanship of
thy tabrets and of thy pipes was
prepared in thee in the day that thou
was created so this being this Angelic
looking creature that's descending to
the Earth is covered in gold and Ezekiel
says that Satan was covered in Gold then
if you look in Ezekiel 28:14 it says
Thou Art the anointed cherub that
coverthe he was the covering cherub why
is it called the covering cherub think
about it think about the most holy place
there was a box in there a golden box
where God dwell and and on top of it
were two cherubs that covered Lucifer
was one of those covering cherubs
Ezekiel is telling us that he was the
Cherub that
coverthe golden cherubs before he was
kicked out of heaven and was replaced by
Gabriel it is assumed is it a
coincidence that this Angelic being who
is descending to Earth is fully covered
in Gold just like he was when he was on
top of that box see Satan wants to be
back in his position he wants to say I'm
not a fallen angel I'm still that angel
that's covered in Gold I'm still that
covering cherub this is Blasphemous
Satan is
saying I I haven't been dispositioned
I'm still that covering cherub covered
in gold and even on msn.com it said for
the closing ceremony the main
performance was spearheaded by a
so-called golden Voyager scouring a
lifeless desolate Earth this is so
prophetic along his way the golden
Voyager stumbled across the goddess Nike
as well as hordes of acrobatic
performers or followers interesting that
they said that these acrobatic
performers were followers who seemingly
brought life back to Earth now if you
don't
know um Satan will be bound to a
desolate Earth it's called the
bottomless pit in the English
translation of the Bible but when you
look uh in Revelation 20:3 it says and
cast him into the bottomless pit this is
the Greek word abusos and the word
abusos means a a void or emptiness it
doesn't this bottomless pit is not a a
very accurate translation in the English
translation he was cast into the void or
an empty space so when you look at what
does this empty space this void mean
you'll see in Jeremiah 4:23 through 27
this is a prophetic vision of when God
comes to earth when when Christ returns
and the wicked are consumed by the
brightness of his coming and the
righteous are taken up to meet the Lord
in the air and we will remain with
Christ for a thousand years and we will
rule and Reign and we're going to go
through the books that says the books
are open and we're going to get to see
the case of every Wicked person that's
not in heaven with us and when we return
after the Thousand Years with Christ to
Earth Revelation says after the thousand
years is finished the rest of the dead
that's the wicked will be raised to life
to judgment and we are going to judge
them Paul said do you not know that you
will judge Angels this is how this goes
but a lot of mainstream Christianity
isn't even teaching this they're
teaching that the that Christ is going
to return and set up this Millennial
Reign Kingdom on Earth and we're going
to live in this perfect world with Jesus
and for some reason after a thousand
years Satan's going to be released and
he's going to deceive a number like the
sand of the sea that doesn't give hope
for anyone it's hard enough to endure
until the end and to make it into the
kingdom and then in their view after a
thousand years you will most likely be a
number like the sand of the sea that's
deceived by the enemy but that is not
what the Bible says when Christ Returns
the de the dead in Christ and the
righteous will be caught up to meet the
Lord in the air the wicked be consumed
by the brightness of his coming who does
that leave on Earth Satan and his fallen
angels and it says right here I beheld
the Earth and low it was without form
and void this is that abusos we're
talking about and the heavens and they
had no light I beheld the mountains and
low they trembled and all the hills
moved lightly I beheld and lo there was
no man and all the birds of Heaven were
fled I beheld and lo the fruitful place
was a Wilderness and all the cities
thereof were broken down at the presence
of the Lord and by his Fierce anger for
thus hath the Lord said the whole land
shall be desolate yet will I not make a
full end of it Christ is saying when he
comes he's going to make the Earth
desolate Satan's going to be bound here
to this desolate Earth for a
Thousand-Year death row sentence
thinking about what he's done he's going
to see the broken down cities he's going
to see the the bones of the people who
were consumed by the brightness of his
coming
and he knows that when Christ returns
with his Believers that he is going to
be destroyed and notice it says that
they're they're describing that this
being coming from the heavens descending
to Earth is coming to a lifeless
desolate
Earth notice he's looking at this being
the goddess Nike who is Nike or in
ancient Greek religion the goddess of
Victory so this is Satan saying I will
be victorious he's looking up at this
symbol of Victory and he's saying I will
be Victorious and you see that these
followers they called them these demonic
beings are lifting up this ring on this
desolate Earth there's nothing but
broken down things and there's this ring
and it's the symbol of the sun you
notice this symbol over here it's a a
it's a a cross The Sun Cross that says
The Sun Cross also called solar cross
Sun wheel or wheel cross is one of the
oldest symbols dating back to
prehistoric cultures it has been found
around the world and holds different
interpretations to various cultures
including Christianity Odin Pagan and
Wiccan but this is the oldest symbol the
the oldest religion outside of believing
in Yahweh is Sun worship and it came in
many forms Baal was a bull with a a suis
in his horns Sun worship came in many
forms but most of the world is either
worshiping God or they're worshiping the
Sun or the serpent or the dragon in this
religious ritual this ceremony they're
lifting up their hands in worship to the
sun wheel The Sun Cross and then you see
all these demonic beings lift up Satan
as their master and they're saying he
will be victorious notice they're still
on this desolate Earth they're going to
bring life to this earth
supposedly then the ceremony ended with
a Himel ironically what happens in a
church service we open with himels we
end with himels we have an opening and
closing ceremony and in between you have
the service that's exactly what happened
at the Olympics there was an opening
song to prepare the hearts and minds of
people then there was these ceremonies
or religious ritual and then they closed
in a hymn we're going to find out what
that hymn was from the Olympic Games
this is official yes that is a piano
suspended in midair the hymn to Apollo
like you've never heard it before but
this guy Elaine rash he was the one that
was performing on this vertical piano
he's done it before and in this video he
describes where his inspiration came
from notice it says Solstice to Solstice
the solstice is a pagan
uh practice a pagan belief and he
says he said and has decided to position
the audience in a way to look at the sky
so he's saying that he purposely
position the audience position the
audience in a way to look at the sky
what's in the sky the sun where does the
Sun come from it says and I decided in
Solstice to Solstice to have the
audience sit on the deck chairs facing
the East this is not just a coincidence
this is not just accident he's literally
telling you there was a reason that he
faced the audience facing the sun their
chairs were were kicked backwards so
that they could look upwards towards the
east he's telling you he's admitting
that this is purposeful he's telling you
it's called Solstice a solstice he's
telling you that he is a pagan and that
he's trying to trick everyone else into
worshiping the way he does look towards
the east and worship the Bible says I
think it was in Ezekiel he says that um
that the people were rejecting God and
they started turning their temples
towards the east because they worshiped
the Sun and this is what we see
happening right here A Hymn is a
religious song or poem of praise to God
or a God I think it's interesting that
they even use the hymn to Apollo right
there in the description who is Apollo
you can find out right there on
olympics.com and they say Apollo was the
god of moral order and music but his
main capacity was to protect the art of
divination so literally when people
filled the stadiums from all over the
world went to Paris to watch these to
participate in a
ceremony they were tricked into looking
up towards the east and being a part of
a
to Apollo the one who protects the art
of divination why is that important
because divination is the practice of
seeking knowledge of it of the future or
Unknown by a supernatural means is that
bad the Bible says in Deuteronomy 1810
it says there shall not be found among
you anyone of anyone that maketh his son
or daughter to pass through the fire or
that useth
divination or an observer of time or en
chanter or a witch divination is
witchcraft it's fortunetelling and yet
this guy was able to convince and trick
the whole audience into participating in
a pagan ritual to Apollo and it's right
here on the Olympics website after that
they Clos out the Olympic Games it says
right here in their tweet it says and
now the end is near I think that's
interesting I don't think that's a
coincidence the end is near and so we
Face the final curtain as we bid
farewell to the Paris 2024 Olympic
flame this person uh youit treats us to
a spine tingling rendition of my way
what is my way why would you pick this
song What is the song my way that you're
ending this big religious ritual with
it's
a song by Frank Sinatra that is deemed
the most satanic song ever sung
especially for its time it was one of
the first songs that was openly satanic
and I asked chat GPT why was this song
considered satanic and it says Frank
Sinatra song my way is often considered
controversial and has been labeled by
some as satanic or morally problematic
due to its lyrics which emphasizes
individualism and self-reliance to the
point of rejecting external Authority or
guidance here are a few reasons why it
has been viewed this way emphasis on
self-determination the lyrics of my way
celebrate doing things according to
one's own desires and choices regardless
of the consequences or what others might
think the repeated phrase I Did It My
Way can be seen as a declaration of
independence from Traditional Values
moral teachings or Divine guidance which
some interpret as a rejection of of
humility or submission to a higher
power perceived arrogance the tone of
the song is one of Pride and
self-satisfaction which some critics
argue promotes a self or a sense of
arrogance this attitude contrasts with
religious teachings that emphasize
humility repentance and the recognition
of human fallibility contradiction to
religious principles in many religions
or in Many religious Traditions the idea
of surrendering to God will seeking
Divine guidance and living according to
moral or spiritual laws is Paramount my
way can be interpreted as advocating for
the opposite where personal desires and
decisions take precedence over any form
of higher authority whether it be God
Society or moral principles association
with sin the idea of doing things my way
without regard for consequences or moral
considerations can be seen as em
embodying the essence of Sin from a
religious perspective where sin is often
understood as putting one's own will
above God's will cultural backlash
during the time when my way was released
there was a cultural shift towards
greater individualism and secularism
which some religious groups viewed with
suspicion with suspicion or alarm the
song became symbolic of a broader
movement away from Traditional Values
and towards a more self-centered secular
world viw so the song my way is a
satanic Anthem Satan's saying look I
know God has laws but I'm going to do it
my way I will Ascend above the heights
of the clouds I will be like the most
high and I'm going to do it my way and
the whole purpose is to convince the
world to be Lawless lawlessness will
abound in the last days when all the
world will do things their own way do
what thou Wilt shall be the whole of the
law Alistar Crowley said the most
satanic wickedest man alive self
proclaimed by himself he said do it my
way and why would you end a
familyfriendly sporting event with a
song like that because it's not an
accident because it didn't just seem
like oh that would be a cool song to
sing at the end there was a reason and
it fit the whole scheme of the of all
the ceremonies that Satan is going to
descend to a desolate Earth that he's
going to be bound here but he thinks
that he's going to be victorious that
he's still the covering cherub decked in
Gold but he's not and we know according
to prophecy that when Christ returns he
will be destroyed and after the Thousand
Years ends he will be destroyed all the
wicked will be destroyed and we'll get
to live in a perfect world with no pain
no sorrow are you ready for that these
people are preparing for the end are you
preparing for the end are you ready for
Christ's second coming we know that it's
coming soon we see all the signs of the
times around us we know that the end is
near but so many people are asleep so
many people are just eating and drinking
and marrying and giving in marriage like
the Bible says the days of Noah that I
think the church is sleeping more than
the secular World these people know
what's going on and they are preparing
to fight against the coming of Christ as
Revelation says that Satan is going to
round up all the kingdoms of the world
just like at this event All Peoples were
together
like in the days of Babel all the people
have become one and they're watching and
participating and cheering on for these
ceremonies that are blatantly satanic
and occultic we need to be ready for
Christ's second coming we need to stop
participating in these Pagan originated
things such as the Olympics stay tuned
because Aubry and I are going to be
doing a a breakdown probably Aubrey's
gonna break it down she's going to be
talking about the pagan origins of the
Olympics and how it's not even hidden
you can find it on their very own
website this is nothing more than a
celebration of Zeus and Apollo and all
these gods and how many Christians are
watching this without a a thought of
what's really going on and when they get
those captive audience you are now
participating in their religious
ceremony I hope you like this video if
you did please give it a thumbs up
please share this with family and
friends if you know people who are
watching the Olympics especially
Christians let them see the truth the
truth will make you free that's what
this channel is all about we're going to
get to the truth and we're going to be
candid with it we're not going to
sugarcoat it we're not going to hold
anything back we're going to tell it in
love because we love you we care about
you we don't want you to be
deceived and that's what this is all
about exposing deception deciphering
deception if you would like to support
this channel we do this out of Faith
Aubrey and I have stepped away from a
paycheck to go and and do what God has
called us to do to start this channel to
start our own Ministry so we are pushing
the truth out there it is cool to know
the truth it's cool to use your brain
and to be smart we love you thank you
for being here God bless you guys and we
will see you next time on the candid
truth